[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs le premier de
cette nouvelle année chaque jeudi les
anciens l'essentiel des informations
pour passer un bon week-end dans les
yvelines et tout de suite le sommaire de
cette semaine 140 concurrents à soutenir
ce week-end le 17e open de tennis de la
verrière des buts
au programme deux tableaux simples dames
et simple monsieur à voisins le
bretonneux quatre groupes vont se
partager la scène de la salle de la tour
a meta sauce organise une soirée punk
avec cette affiche et coupe et l'agenda
complet de vos sorties au programme du
théâtre des châteaux gonflables et du
cinéma
on commence l'année de manière sportive
ce week-end on débute la 17e édition de
l'open de tennis de la verrière jusqu'au
2 février deux tableaux simples dames et
messieurs un tournoi ouvert à tous les
licenciés de tennis de plus de 16 ans
des matchs en journée des matches en
soirée pour les 140 participants pour y
assister direction les courts couverts
du parc sportif il est constant de la
commune on commence par les non classés
et puis on finira par les meilleurs qui
le tournoi est ouvert à 3,6 que depuis
cette année puisqu'elle faisait de
nouveau test c'est une nouveauté nous
ont dit qu'ils ont ouvert jusqu'à 5-6
avant et cette année on l'enverra 3,6 un
bon gros concert punk qui va faire mal
aux oreilles alors mais tu as hausse
donne la couleur la salle de la tour va
vivre une soirée 100% punk et on en
parle avec nos deux invités bonjour à
tous les deux florent se trouve à vous
êtes chargé de communication de
l'association christopher vous êtes le
bassiste d'un des groupes participants
les poissons non je vais me tourner
d'abord vers florence la musique punk
c'est un des styles que l'association
veut mettre en avant
alors on fait relativement beaucoup de
style en fait dans nos concerts en
simple le but est d'explorer
d'expérimenter un peu tous styles ont
fait du métal du pain du rock des fois
on va dans des styles qui sont aussi
complètement inexploré comme le dob par
exemple là on a choisi le poc parce que
c'est quelque chose qui se fait pas
beaucoup sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines on a décidé de le
mettre un petit peu l'honneur
exceptionnellement et je trouve qu'en
plus on a des groupes punks dans nos
studios
et oui des groupements
ce soir est là c'est aussi l'idée de
mettre en avant les groupes locaux à
exactement en fait c'est un peu aussi le
credo qu'on défend d'habitude
c'est-à-dire d'apporter un peu de
visibilité pour groupes amateurs à
travers des têtes d'affiché donc là on a
deux affiches et de groupes locaux donc
ça s'équilibre plutôt bien on va
commencer par les groupes locaux parce
que l'un des membres est avec nous à
christopher vous êtes
monde des poissons morts c'est le nombre
ou vous le créez en 2010 et vous
connaissez très bien saint quentin en
yvelines est ce qu'on va faire une
petite présentation sur bas sur un beau
poème où que j'aille était criante 2010
ne compte pas fêter nos 10 ans en 2016
on a créé un objet qui ça n'arrête pas
une manche en devant ta gueule désolé et
ça détend ça donne le ton est donc là
cette année on prévoit un nouvel ep
on appellera les vagues dans vos
influences on voit bérurier noir tagada
jones qu'est ce qui vous plaît
qu'est ce qui vous inspire
malheureusement pas que des années 80
était vachement influencé mais c'étaient
des textes engagés et on essaye de ba et
perdurer cette séquence finances n'a
quand tu nous as qu'une plaie justement
on va voir un petit peu votre style on
va écouter un titre s'appelle et à
durance celui-là il a un peu moins d'un
an
[Musique]
on pourrait entendre samedi soir celui
ci oui on a répété à fond pour un
concert comme ça c'est des titres que
vous connaissez cette liste ont depuis
longtemps donc long et on est prêts on
est serein ya pas de socios montboyer à
celle de ton est donné
florence
vous l'avez dit ya des têtes d'affiché
c'est des gens qui sont déjà venus sur
la scène de la salle de la tour ou pas à
washington de 4 mais en revanche dans
une mercenaries on a des personnes qui
faisait partie antérieurement de notre
groupe dans streetpilot par exemple et
qui sont déjà venus lors d'une
précédente soirée punk à la salle de la
tour vous avez brawn ont fait un autre
nom aussi les vaches et washington dead
cats c'est un groupe majeur de la scène
alternative tout à fait ça va bien
conclure la soirée
ah bah ça va très bien qu'au classement
et washington 4 c'est vraiment faim dans
le milieu folk
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis
très longtemps ils ont 35 ans de scène
en fait derrière déjà douze 12 albums
sortis fin vraiment ils ont enchaîné je
crois de 1500 concerts partout dans
l'europe
donc c'est vraiment un groupe
d'expérience qui a bien marché qui a
aussi tourné avec les béruriers noirs
donc des grands noms de la scène punk
est justement là aussi on répète un
extrait
[Musique]
qui a souffert des groupes comme ça vous
allez faire les premières parties que
vous avez déjà fait mais ça donne des
inspirations ça motive on va chercher
aussi peut-être des conseils pour plus
tard on avait fait la première partie
c'était deux ans trois ans il y avait
c'était no one et one on sait enfin
l'énergie qu'elles peuvent dégager ces
personnes là bas si on le prend et il y
avait d'autres non et c'est en citant y
en a eu des premières n'est pas malin et
florence à te faire venir des groupes
comme ça c'est pas compliqué ils
viennent avec plaisir ils viennent
partager leur amour de leur musique
alors oui en général ça se passe plutôt
bien quand ils sont contents aussi de
rencontrer d'autres personnes mais en
fait c'est un peu notre notre façon de
voir les choses
enfin pour vous pas vous le cacher même
dans les loges en fait en général il ya
une communication entre les groupes
qu'on voit rarement dans d'autres
entrent dans d'autres endroits
c'est pour le public et c'est aussi donc
pour les musiciens qui sont sur cette
machine
tous les deux d'être revenu en plateau
alors les fans de punk ne manquez pas le
rendez vous la soirée débute à 20h c'est
à la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux on parlera plaisir
maintenant pour partager un stage
découverte de théâtre l'association
plaisir oise pour la promotion du
théâtre et du spectacle vivant à temps
parents grands parents et enfants pour
une journée d'échangés l'occasion de
partager ensemble une journée autour de
petits jeux sur le corps la voix ou
encore l'espace scénique le stage sera
animé par un binôme une comédienne et
musicienne pour s'inscrire les
informations s'affichent à l'écran on
écoute un mot de la présidente de
l'association c'est un stage qui est co
animé on a l'habitude de travailler
ensemble et en famille on a eu une
première édition l'année dernière qui a
super bien marché et on s'est dit qu'il
fallait recommencer c'est un vrai temps
de partage qu'on n'a pas le temps de
faire forcément travaillons pour et
les retours qu'on a eue nous ont
confortés dans l'idée qu'il fallait
recommencer à plaisir toujours
l'association lecture et dialogues
propose une rencontre avec une écrivaine
l'invité maylis de kerangal l'auteur de
réparer les vivants le 14 janvier elle
vient présenter et dédicacer son dernier
livre un monde à portée de main sautez
rebondissait ou encore joué depuis la
fin du mois de novembre les enfants ont
un nouveau lieu deux jeux à saint
quentin en yvelines le centre commercial
sqy ouest accueille sa demande un espace
de structures gonflables regarder elle
les châteaux gonflables ont remplacé les
joué depuis le 23 novembre à nantes
s'est installé à skywest à montigny le
bretonneux plus de 800 mètres carrés
destiné aux enfants de 2 à 12 ans en
premier la nouvelle politique du centre
qui s'axe entièrement sur de loisirs et
l'emplacement est idéal dans un centre
commercial c'est rare en france c'est
des structures qu'on retrouve
généralement en extérieur pour bien
passer un moment en famille les parents
peuvent profiter du centre commercial
ils peuvent profiter de
faire du shopping d'aller au cinéma et
venir après la séance de cinéma par
exemple
donc c'est vraiment une sortie familiale
fondée par une société de location de
structures gonflables et d'événementiel
fun landes propose piscine à balles
animaux sauteurs et jeux de kermesse
c'est sympa ça permet d'avoir des
animations juste à côté de chez nous
[Musique]
foehn ont découvert les mercredis
samedis dimanches et pendant les
vacances scolaires et les et qui
proposeront bientôt un service de
garderie et des créneaux pour adultes
sont en train d'être repensée en ce
début d'année on retrouve les salles de
cinéma de saint quentin en yvelines
cette semaine c'est hugo basquin de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois qui nous invite dans
les salles obscures
on les côtes cette semaine dans les
salles de l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous vous proposons de
venir voir ou revoir le neuvième épisode
star wars
l'ascension de skywalker en version
numérique française 2d ou 3d
l'occasion également pour vous de
découvrir ou redécouvrir l'exposition
dédiée à la guerre des étoiles dans nos
locaux
faites vite car elle se termine ce
dimanche 12 janvier une semaine variés
dans notre programmation puisque nous
proposons des films d'animation pour
petits et grands avec vic le viking à
partir de 3 ans les incognitos ce à
partir de 6 ans ou encore sous
avertissement le fantastique film de
jérémy clapin j'ai perdu mon corps ayant
reçu cinq prix et six nominations en
2019 un hommage aux membres fantômes aux
disparus sans doute l'un des meilleurs
films d'animation français des années
2010 en sortie nationale nous avons
également le fabuleux film d'animation
l'extraordinaire voyage de marc ona deux
ans qu'à damian qui a été nommé trois
fois au festival du film d'animation
d'annecy en 2019 enfin nous terminerons
par les deux drames la vérité qui met en
scène les retrouvailles d'une mère
actrice jouée par catherine deneuve et
de sa fille est le dernier de terrence
malick très primé traîneau mais intitulé
une vie cachée fiction inspirée de faits
réels nous exposant la résist
ans nazi du temps de la seconde guerre
mondiale nous vous invitons donc à venir
voir la variété à l'espace philippe
noiret et nous en profitons pour vous
souhaiter une excellente année 2020 et
tous nos voeux de bonheur
[Musique]
on quitte maintenant les yvelines pour
un détour par la capitale vient grand
paris vous fait découvrir le spectacle
d'une histoire culte peter pan est de
retour à bobino quinze comédiens
chanteurs et danseurs les navigue vol
jouent chantent et dansent
je ne veux jamais devenir un homme se
veut toujours rester à kars venez vous
replonger en famille dans le monde
fantastique de peter pan à bobino depuis
15 ans le héros de tous les enfants
revient sur scène pour un voyage vers le
pays imaginaire accompagné de wengé ses
jeunes frères
sans oublier la terrible bandeau de
pirate mené par le capitaine crochet ce
conte poétique est une réadaptation
fidèles de l'histoire originale créée il
ya plus de son temps je le veux
c'est vrai qu'on connaît vraiment peter
pan crochet ou angie et tous les héros
de cette aventure par disney qui a
beaucoup populariser cette histoire avec
le film d'animation
mais avant d'être ce film de disney
c'était un roman est une pièce qui ont
été écrites au tout début du siècle
dernier en 1904 par james matthew barrie
et donc je reviens au spectacle
guy et martine ont créé peter pan le
spectacle musical à partir du roman et
de la pièce de james matthew barrie
c'est à mon sens un spectacle qui est
très très très fidèle à l'esprit de
james matthew barrie et dans lequel il
ya des petites parenthèses chanter et
danser
peter pan tourne autour d'un thème
important celui de la figure maternelle
si notre héros a préféré fuir sa famille
pour rester un enfant toute sa vie
l'histoire nous rappelle qu'une mère est
essentiel pour s'épanouir dédié aux
enfants
le spectacle est un succès et il est
impossible de tricher face à un jeune
public un adulte qui s'ennuient ça veut
dire bon bah je m'ennuie mais tant pis
alors soit 800 d'or il trop rend son mal
en patience
un enfant ça peut pas faire ça à un
enfant quand ça sent nuit ça le dise à
cris ça bouge ça veut partir etc
il faut tenir ce public-là en haleine
pendant une heure et demie et j'avoue
que sur ce spectacle on a énormément de
chance parce qu'on les sent avec nous du
début à la fin et d'ailleurs il
participe au déroulement de l'histoire
c'est un spectacle très rythmé ya
beaucoup de décors différents comme on
l'a dit avec des passages chanter danser
une gigue irlandaise un quadrille qui
vit les temps en lmp2 repent le
spectacle musical c'est un bobino
jusqu'au 22 février 2020
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site loisirs merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
on